you're telling me i've got to forget
about what the democrats are doing right
now
present tense because it might set
a bad precedent for the future even
though the democrats are already doing
it right now
this reminds me of what what we always
hear from the squishy republicans
on big tech censorship they say we can't
ever use
the government to stop the left from
censoring conservatives right now in the
here and now
because if we do that then they might
use it to censor us in the future
even though they're already censoring us
in the present well then i don't care
about that hypothetical i care about
what's happening right now
i'm not going to give the left an actual
victory right now
so that i can maybe win a hypothetical
victory in the future
after i've already lost right now that
doesn't make any
sense i'm worried about the present
tense
not the precedence can i get an amen to
that
we ask it in the name of the
monotheistic god
brahma and god known by many
names by many different faiths
a man and a woman
amen and a woman that is some silly
uh democratic representative i don't
even remember his name
uh this democratic representative was
giving this sort of prayerful
invocation and of course he doesn't know
the meaning of the word amen amen does
not have anything to do with being male
or female
it's a very ancient hebrew word and it
has has nothing to do with sex
whatsoever
okay fair enough so we're all laughing
at this guy we're all correcting him
i think that's the wrong strategy i
think that completely misunderstands
what's happening
conservatives are getting this all wrong
in the same way that they get political
correctness
wrong more generally it is not
enough to laugh at these guys while
we're busy
laughing and correcting these guys on
these silly redefinitions
and ridiculous etymologies
they're scoring victories
that's what remember latinx tinx
remember how we all joked about that
remember how we all joked about
uh turning chairman into chair person or
chairwoman that was a little i guess it
was in the 90s people joked about that
then it happened the latinx thing
is being totally mainstreamed he or her
zur being totally mainstream the
singular they being totally mainstreamed
what happens is the left doesn't care
about these etymologies the left doesn't
care
they're not going to feel embarrassed if
you say wait actually amen has nothing
to do with men or women
you're gonna say yeah whatever now it's
political
now you better say amen or a woman it's
i i
have a strong hunch that this phrase is
actually going to be mainstreamed beyond
that listen to the new standard he says
he invokes the monotheistic god the name
of the monotheistic god brahma
brahma is not the monotheistic god
brahma is the name of a pagan deity from
south asia
that is a foreign deity in the in
the united states but there's the
establishment of a new standard and this
new standard is secular liberalism and
the new standard is enforced by
politically correct speech codes and
politically correct behavior codes and
we giggle and we correct them and they
enforce the standard
there is a way around this but it's
going to be very difficult for
conservatives
the way that the left is able to
trample the culture and establish these
new standards and get people to start
saying a woman which they're actually
going to do
remember they changed rest in peace to
rest in power rest in power doesn't make
any sense but the left all says it now
so i mean i could the life changed
christmas trees into holiday trees what
holiday are they talking about the only
holiday that has a tree is christmas but
still people now talk about
holiday trees how how do they do it
because the left is willing to defend
their new politically correct standards
they're willing to go out on a limb and
say
you need to use the language that we
want you to use
and the only way conservatives has
responded is hey
we're not going to tell you that you
should say a certain thing or behave in
a certain way
we would never impose on you we would
never force our views on you you can't
legislate those sort of things
but we just won't just please don't make
us do it
not how it works folks not how speech
codes work not how language works not
how
behavior works either
the christmas tree is going to be you're
going to call it a christmas tree or
you're going to call it a holiday tree
but you're going to call it something
it's going to have a name
and the left is trying to push this few
either we're going to
pray to god or we're going to pray to
brahma you're not going to pray to both
you can't you can't pray to both
actually
and so that so the way political
correctness advances is they destroy the
old standards
they say you're not allowed to say chair
man you're not allowed to pray to god
you're not allowed to say amen you're
not allowed to call it a christmas tree
you're not allowed you're not allowed
you're not allowed you're not allowed
that's offensive that's wrong and
because they believe in their new
standard they're willing to enforce it
we don't really believe in it anymore
the way to actually fight back against
this is to publicly say amen a lot and
really believe it
the way to fight back against this is to
actually have a robust
i suppose you'd say traditional culture
which is heavily heavily christian
culture
and actually believe in it and actually
be willing to make claims about it and
actually say
there is one god his name is god and
that's the god that we worship in the
united states
and we don't worship a bunch of other
gods are you willing to make that claim
are you willing to go out there and
exert those standards are you willing to
say hey
not only is it not the case that men can
become women
but it is disordered that men should
behave like women
and we should discourage them from doing
it are you willing to go that far
are you willing to actually and by the
way when i say that far i mean the thing
everyone would have agreed on 10 years
ago
the idea that men are not women because
the the the rut
that conservatives and the right are
stuck in is they'll say hey
i don't want to make any claims look if
you want if you're a man and you want to
pretend to be a woman that's totally
fine it's
i just don't make me do it just don't
well in that case you've established
the principle that a man really can
become a woman or that it's totally
normal or totally acceptable
you've established the principle that a
christmas tree yeah maybe it's not a
christmas tree you've established the
principle that maybe
the god that that our nation has
historically worshipped
that we can find reference to him in the
declaration of independence
and in state constitutions and
in the connecticut code and in the
writings of all of our forefathers
that that maybe that god's actually
brahma right
maybe uh it's not though
and unless we are willing to make
substantive moral claims
which frankly i think most conservatives
are not because i think we're cowardly
and
we think it's impolite or something and
we don't even really believe it much
ourselves
unless we're going to do that you're
going to get amen you're going to you're
not going to get it just amen you're
going to get a woman you're going to get
political correctness this is why
political correctness advances
we laugh at it we joke about it and they
get the wins
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so
everyone wading through the wasteland of
youtube knows that we've got the
absolute top content out there
[Music]
you